WE GO.BLUES TURN IT OVER.
BOUNCING BACK TO A SHOT.
THERE IS TIPPETT, HE FIRES UP
THE
IN, DIAGONALLY INTO THE CORNER.
WALKER SHOOT.
THE FLYERS HAVE IT AT THE RASEN
THOMAS WANTED IT UNDER HIS FEET.
KICKRS THE ZONE.
WAIT AND FIGHT THE
LOGAN BROWN WINS THE DRAW.PERCE
EFFICIENCY.
HERE IS LEDDY , FOR ST. LOUIS.T
WORKING ON THAT POWER PLAY.
BACK IN THE OTHER WAY, BRANDON,
SAVEBLUE LINE.
>> Dom: I
THAT TRICKLED, BARELY, OVER THE
LINE.SCHENN.
HERE IS PERRON IN THE CIRCLE.
OFF MISTAKE
WITH THE SHOT FROM TH
IN ST. LOUIS.
BLAZES FORWARD.
TARASENKOPAST, INTENDED FOR
ING
>> Mike: THERE IS O'REILLY.
HE MOVES ALONG.
O'REILLY TAKES
NHL GAME, HIS FIRST NHL GOAL
HE PUTS HIM IN A TOUGH SPOT
WHERE HE HAS TO MAKE A
DECISION